what's up everybody welcome back to
GameSpot Krauss kind of funny no we're
not throwing a YouTube stage Chloe
they're playing Smash Brothers for you
to everyone stay here on gamespot comm
slash g3 never go to youtube again
except when this ends then go to
youtube.com slash kind of funny
all right great I'm Greg this is Alexa
from GameSpot there's the crossover we
talk about all the time yeah then we're
here to talk about life is strange so
the developer Michel is here to talk to
us and of course Ashley playing Chloe in
the game hello hello now I like life is
strange
I enjoy this game I get excited for this
game Alexa is on another level of land a
little writing fanfiction about the
students are you actually know I could
spin us a tail right now oh I was the
back story of a character uh so Victoria
is actually is actually angry and sad
because she's actually part cyborg from
the future and knows how the story ends
and the apocalypse happens that she's
gone back in time to try and try and
stop it
but she's just mean to everybody because
she can't express what's going to happen
cyborgs don't even bother she's a cyborg
from future Corps come back to save the
world Tori is the Terminator
she's a terminate okay Victoria is this
real story so you can have that one for
free
does that bother them too yeah here's
what we need to come to grips with right
away how spoiler we do won't do we want
to get you were talking and we were
talking I'm down to just spoil it if
you're here right now here's what you
need to know life is strange is awesome
go buy the season pass play the games
this will be on demand later
I don't mind you going out to check out
what's happening on YouTube so I say we
spoil everything
gloves are rotten though hey Troy oh
thank your feet I don't know we
shouldn't maybe spout too much to the
power line everybody stay here don't go
anywhere
we'll leave out some key points we
should so I guess then I'll kick it off
with I mean Michelle did you expect this
to resonate the way it has um to be
honest no we didn't when we started
making the game we were really what we
wanted to make the game we we wanted to
play we wanted to we didn't add any
pressure when we started because we
didn't add the publisher yet so we just
get we just thought okay let's let's
make the game we are we want to make who
wants to play and let's forget about
target audience forget about marketing
so we just worked on the game we wanted
to create we created the character we
wanted to tell the story about and and
we were really lucky to find Square Enix
who just loved the game we shot to them
and they said okay let's go let's let's
do this game and after a really the Cubs
on one when we saw so many good
reactions from the players on Twitter on
the social networks so many fan are so
many cosplayers we were really amazed
because we we didn't we didn't accept
this kind of big resonance and and big
success with the community so we're
really really happy and since it's
really hard to work on an episodic game
it's really helping us helping the teams
to to walk out on the next episode by
looking at all the also great let's play
videos and stuff like this it's really
it's really helping us now is that a
double-edged sword because of course is
episodic
you get to see people like I love this
I'm connecting with the characters and I
want to do more but then you also get
the chance to second-guess every
decision you make right yes we can do
that and we did it a little bit so the
story was fully written since the
beginning we know where we're going we
know what's what is the train doesn't
stop for anybody yeah we know what will
be the different endings we know where
what's the major of scenes but we still
have the leisure to to take into account
some of the player feedbacks and for
example we've seen that some characters
where we are loved even more than we saw
that would be and we decided to just may
sometimes to add a bit more dialogue
with them to just tweak a bit of the
scenes to reflect what we read from the
player so that's one of the perks of of
doing episodic even if it's only a small
development time we still have time to
just adjust a bit based on the on the
player feedbacks and we really love to
read the player feedbacks how long have
you guys had the idea for this game
because it's it's it's a high school
drama mixed with all the sci-fi and
craziness mm-hmm I think it started
after we finished our previous game
remember me and in remember me it was a
it was a fast-paced action adventure
game that we had those sequences the
memory mix where you could just go
inside the pit board memory and try some
different interaction to provoke and
cause and consequence effect and we
thought we loved this this idea and we
thought we should make a full game with
a very slow pacing an adventure game
using this kind of mechanism and really
focusing on the choice and consequence
aspect of this and that's why the
beginning of the process so we we
started to to try to find what would be
the best gameplay and that's how we
created the rewind power and then we
worked on the story the character as a
setting to be sure that everything would
be resonating with that and working
really to be really cohesive with with
the power with so that's why we have
this our direction that we have those
characters that why we shoot the setting
of a high school and because when you
were teen it's one of the time of your
life when your decisions will really
affect you as an adult so it's a really
good period to to to question shade
choice and consequence ease and and
destiny all right final question and I'm
gonna let Alexa go Berger how did you
get involved with the project Ashley was
is they come to you you hear about it
how did it all happen I actually just
got an audition through my agency and I
auditioned originally for Chloe and for
max and which I don't know if you do
that actually maybe um I think yes we
have a lot of voice actors with
auditions for several character yeah
yeah so I remember even when I got the
sides um really connecting and liking
Chloe along and yeah and then I think
you guys knew about hey ash
some of you did I believe I actually and
what's funny is that when we received
all the cast of the voice those are
castings we didn't have the name of
object right so we were listening and
and when we hear we add your you're
tagged with everyone in the office so
okay this is Chloe we're for sure oh and
it's only after that we that we that we
recognize your name and so oh that's
yeah she yeah so we didn't know your
we're famous and we didn't know where
were you where when we when we decided
that two wheels are perfect always for
Chloe
ah well shucks all right now Alexa get
nerdy oh my god okay so my my big thing
with the life is strange is so I was I
was max I had a I was the loner
I was the weirdo kids made fun of me I
was never invited to parties girls spit
in my hair on the bus you know what's
really I was yeah I was like the kid
that got picked on and was like
alienated so something well
right now haha I've made it um so I
really I really identify with the story
of these like young teenage girls so I
guess my question is why why did you
decide to write a story about adolescent
girls mmm I think really it started with
what I said before with the fact that we
were we wanted to talk about choice and
consequences and using this rewind power
which is really a nostalgic power and I
think the iSchool years are not static
for maybe all of us so we really saw
that it was a good good time of a period
of life to to talk about those themes
those choices and consequences and it
hasn't been done that much in video
games you have buried from rock stars
you have obscure from the French
companies there is not many games about
about address on to about teenagers and
it's really hard to be a teenager it's a
really violent world it's it's brutal
and we really saw that using this seems
cool others to talk about much more that
just teen drama so that's why we are and
that's something that's really important
for us in life is change is to talk
about important serious themes so we are
talking about social media bullying
about domestic violence about teen
pregnancy and there was a lot of of
scenes and secondary seems we can we can
develop in a story in a story like this
it's every horrible thing about teenage
years the one thing I go oh yeah every
every horrible thing about being a
teenager plus the the impending end of
the world
trying to fix things um when did you
when during conception of the story did
you start to add that fantasy element
like where did like where did that come
from and we added for the beginning with
the rewind because of course I think the
ability to rewind time is a supernatural
power yes no one has that power who
knows but but but for us weed is a
sci-fi aspect is is not the important
part of life is strange life is strange
is really a story about characters about
intimacy about human emotions and this
this sci-fi element these supernatural
elements this is just a layer that's
added on top of it
to bring some cows and to to add a layer
of excitement about the stories it's a
bit like you know Stephen King is doing
that in his books yeah it's really books
about is writing
so is about people about about human
human human emotions and initiative book
super of our elements are just here to
to steer sing-sing zaps and we are
almost with the same formula this is
what is a character that's important
well as a fan of fantasy sci-fi stuff I
love it and then playing as basically me
just makes me love it even more know my
favorite characters Chloe and I'm not
just saying that because you're sitting
here but you sound like like when I play
the game you sound like you're having a
lot of fun playing her so could you just
like how do you find Chloe when you go
in for a vo session why do you feel
about her
I love Chloe I kind of as as an adult
woman I kind of want to just like give
her a cup of tea and like make sure
she's okay she's gonna be oh yeah like
don't worry Chloe I'm here for you kid
like I just feel like uh but yeah I mean
everyone I think has like you said it's
a very I think the characters of Max and
Chloe are very Universal I'm sure a lot
of girls and even and men too I think
have an experience of being like Max or
feeling like Chloe and so there is this
element of Chloe that like feels very
rejected and alienated and abandoned and
there are definitely parts of me that
resonate very much with that and so
being Chloe is sort of like an aide part
of my brain coming online you know it's
like this one it's the little kid that's
like you know afraid that they're gonna
be left alone and that's kind of yeah
that's just kind of who Chloe is um
being a teenage girl it comes out a lot
in like aggression and angst but it's
this core thing of like she you know can
I say that better dad I mean it's
obviously pretty yeah yes she lost her
dad so that's the ultimate abandonment
so um yeah so she just has that kind of
core to her and I think just like you
said yeah with max Chloe I think is a
very resonant character because she has
that sort of emotional core to her
that's very human yeah yeah without uh
without spoiling anything for people
watching I already told you play the
game I know what you just get it it's a
season pass it's really good
oh I didn't know what happens because I
didn't work on the game so I had a
couple of really horrible gut-punch
moments that just left me on the floor
in the fetal position for a while um but
you obviously know what what happens so
when you play
play as you're with you're playing like
do you ever like think like oh I know
what's happening like does that affect
like how you play yourself I don't know
I completely like box that no no no I
don't how do you I know you mean like
when I go to actually play the game yeah
what does except I'm not gonna say this
cuz that'll make that happen
yeah it's interesting because I yeah I
know I know the different routes that
everything could take but I kind of play
it just as a normal player and even
though I know it's sort of like a movie
that I've seen before but still enjoy so
and I will remember it's also an
interesting thing because obviously like
I'm also listening to my performance and
and critiquing it because that's what
you do when you accident you here and
back but then also I kind of just have
Vietnam flashbacks to being in the booth
not being on flashbacks but like I just
think about it flashback boo flashbacks
so um cuz it's a very emotional
character and I love every every vo
session I love going into but it's also
actually kind of emotionally taxing I'm
sure yeah but in a really good way like
it feels like it feels very real and
very visceral and so going back and
playing it is sort of I can't help but
sort of also go back to those moments
because you know I'm hearing myself do
it again yeah uh but yeah I sort of I
still enjoy it just as a player because
it's a beautifully constructed game and
there are also parts of the game that I
you know like any a lot of the stuff
with Victoria or Kate like stuff that I
didn't record with I'm experiencing for
the first time yeah yeah so yeah so with
there's there's one one decision I'm
going to spoil it a little bit there's
one decision in the game that for me I
think is the one of the big polarizing
decisions that I've talked to other
people when I've talked to the people
about the game you're in the diner and
you have the choice between a bacon
omelet and a waffle that's really
important and and I played that for the
first time I think you were there
Roxie's it was four of us and it came up
and half of a shouted bacon and half of
a shattered waffle and we got in a fight
and it was very polarizing what did you
do did waffle okay I did it awful as
well I went bacon come on now
waffles though they're alright but I
don't I don't like sweet stuff that much
I'd rather I love waffles or superior
yeah you know let us know I want to see
you over on the side with my your waffle
but you know our producer is vegetarian
so it was important for us oh no max -
to order vegetarian food if she wants
now you guys have are you guys Twin
Peaks fans cuz there's a lot of like
Twin Peaks rise of course we are major
twin Twin Peaks fans so how do you guys
feel about the reboot coming or the
rudder eat no it's not a reboot please
don't listen to me oh my god are you a
[ __ ] oh I'm really excited about it and
knowing that David Lynch is is directing
all the episodes now but that's really
cool so we'll see but and I am high
hopes for that what about you
you know I actually Twin Peaks is on my
list right now I know I know we're not
always old is huge I actually I'm
working my way through his movies though
so I just watched Mulholland Drive for
the first time recently which is
incredible you should watch it I know I
really want to I'm working my way
through Buffy right now that's but I
just did that but this year is my second
best favorite TV show ever so that's
peaks and then Buffy okay I'm doing a
reversal okay yeah you can actually skip
I think like the latter half of 20
season two that's what I forego just
throw it out and then the movie is just
like yeah it's craziness it's super
crazy yeah um so what kind of misses for
both of you what kind of feedback have
you bought and/or what have you seen
from the game now that it's out there
like what do you see what do you see
people talking about and what are you
hoping they're talking about more oh um
it's it's been awesome people are
talking about the game every time on
we've been quite addicted on the team on
Twitter so even after work we are going
on Twitter
terrible already tore everything to it
but really want to people love it but
she's just watching Twitter all the time
yeah I know I know seeing your baby
deconstructed yeah I think a baby's is
robots
we're back to terminators and no it's
really awesome and people are talking
about everything they're loving the
characters we've seen more than
thousands of fan outs there is really
fan out everywhere and people are
drawing Max and Chloe and the other
character so that's really awesome and
we've seen theories about about Twitter
about the characters a lot of talk also
about woo max will will eventually date
and stuff like this and it's really cool
to see that the guys are so much in
really relating to the Oscar
as it's pretty coder yeah I mean the
feedback has been overwhelmingly
overwhelmingly positive and I always
have people on my Twitter feed when they
find out that I'm Chloe or just knowing
that I'm going yeah they they really
like her which I really appreciate um
yeah I'm also love just how wide of an
appeal it has and I think the c3 is a
great testament to that that there are a
lot more female protagonists that we're
seeing and which is so heartening for me
it's really encouraging we were just
talking about a hip hop gamer if you
guys know him I was obsessing obsessing
a when he plays with his son and it's
just it's awesome to see that it has
such a wide appeal and you know women
can be related to if you're not a woman
it's a possible thing well that's what
games are at their best right yeah they
put you in someone else's shoes and I
think is we've seen the rise of the new
adventure game or the choice game right
where you help you that that's the
easiest way whether it's gone home
whether it's Clementine whether it's
whatever yeah get to be any shoes back
oh right it's more than just bros and
god it's a happenin here we yeah do this
is an art form yeah you are you
mentioned fan art and I was just
reminded of something and I'm uh if you
go on YouTube and type in wrestling is
strange yeah I saw like I saw that video
I have I saw that somebody made a made
um no I think it's like one of the WWE
wrestling games that's awesome and they
change the wrestlers into Max and Chloe
and I'm like Victoria or some man
and just like questing and it's insane
it's crazy Chloe in Victoria are
fighting and then max runs out and
rewinds the jumps in the ring in life so
you hit each other with chairs and they
play like the opening to the game and
it's really strange
that's so actually I've seen also video
which was called case revenge and you
have Cage will just come ups to Nate and
and literally kicks Nathan as with kicks
and and karate moves on what kind of
sort of going on that vein what kind of
stuff have you seen fans make besides
wrestling mods I've seen mods for GTA
where you could have a cow with movie
which is which with and life you spent
on it and and skins of Max and Chloe in
GTA
we've seen some pixel art we've seen the
Blackwell Academy recreated in Minecraft
which in a lot of stuff that's crazy
yeah I seen a lot of banner
yeah people love to ship Max and Chloe
too so that bad yeah that was my next
question that's gonna be the best ending
oh boy
so there's a lot of potential there like
I'm as someone who is I'm reviewing the
game so I played them for the episodes
multiple times but there's a lot of
potential there for them to maybe be a
little bit more than friends know I had
close I had a close girlfriend when I
was younger and like girls are like we
pulled you know strip off to our
underwear and jump in a pool like we
don't care like women are very
comfortable with each other um but
there's a lot of a lot of there might be
something more there like can you talk
about that all foreign for most this is
really a friendship a really strong
friendship story and after that we won't
spoil everything but it still helped to
the player because I was a lot of
choices in the game and a lot of diet
choices and minor and major of choices
you can make and those up to the player
to to really play is version of Max and
see how we want max to to ever but
really at what we really wanted to talk
about is about friendship about
loneliness isolation and it is a
friendship of Max and crew age which is
really strong when they are almost
disconnected with everyone else so
that's was what's really important for
us yeah you got to finish it you really
got to finish it
I'm going what I'm going to finish I'm
not and also there's a plan I've already
bought his best buddy alright don't
worry about it I'm gonna finish it I'm
gonna play the whole game [ __ ] I want to
talk theories just do it I haven't do it
you're here any three I'm totally locked
in I'm not there yeah so I have a theory
that rachel has the same power as Max
and screwed everything up and what's
happening is because of her that's my
theory we've seen a lot of stories on
July the game can I have an and then a
rule we have is to never answer to any
series because of course and swing to
one story would maybe say this is wrong
oh this is right and we won't spoil so
we let you continue thinking about
you're Italian and you have to say and
sorry that's nice thanks for having
stories it's really cool we know we know
when they are surprising us again
I play with the I play with my boyfriend
and we always like for hours afterwards
is like theories and crackpot life is
strange theories so the episode three
just came out do you know when we can
expect Episode four so we don't have a
film release date no it's we're
finishing the episode and it should be
the same window of a tweak or work
between each episode but we should say
when it's done but it shouldn't be too
long
well we will we will we get the rest of
the episodes this year like do you see
it yes we're still aiming to give this
eight week window between each episode
so you can make the approximate if count
is that good
you gotta hurry up oh my god Alexa I
want to talk it right been busy
already I II think all this materialized
you think these guests just call me hey
you're somebody's got to be out there
again
it's me Greg Miller CEO of kind of funny
calm everyone's livelihood on me now
talking about pressure you said of
course the games been written you knew
you know where you're going as you've
gone through and you're making the game
episode episode are you running into any
weird like you know it's one thing to
have the whole story the outline but
then you get there you start we start
manipulating time in the game I feel
like that's when there's all the
paradoxes that can come and you in
episode three you're like well then this
happens they're like well no like
because in episode two is this a problem
it seems like you'd have strings all
over your office yes we have yes it's
really a lot of a mace massive headache
when you're working with time travel and
even more in a game with choice and
consequences because we have around four
to five major choice in each episode and
ten to fifteen minor chases and we are
keeping all those into account so the
game is recording everything and in each
episode we are really using everything
we have to change some measure on minor
stuff in the game can be a new text
message receive a new headline on the
newspaper emails max would receive
change of dialogues a new character
changing environment and bigger stuff
like maybe your character dying or not
and stuff like that so if you add is if
you add to this rewind ability it's
really really complicated
we have excel files that are like more
like sixty pages just of
all your choices and
and we need to be sure that we are
checking everything that's where we are
managing we managed to do it for fun oh
so we are still struggling to finish to
finish it but we on the right track
you're doing a great job I feel like
that would be the thing that would drive
me crazy it's running into some time
paradoxes ah yeah
God dang it so then now actually are you
totally wrapped like all your stuffs
done we just finished recording episode
4 but I haven't started episode 5 so you
don't even know all the endings yeah I
know what happens in episode 5 yeah hey
secrets yeah I won't say anything so now
we talked you know about strong female
characters starting to be a thing the
fact that we have these games that you
know Square is able to get behind to be
like that why do you think we're
starting to hit that stride right I feel
like we've been talking about it forever
but this is the e3 right where it's even
Horizons main character seems to be
female and all the stuffs happening why
are we hitting the stride right now it's
for both I would say it's about time um
I don't know I just think the way we are
creating character I don't know we are
not we never started like this friend
saying we want a female character sure
we just had the rewind which we were
starting to search for the best story
and the best characters and we had we
had a male character which was drafted
out at a point and when we were walking
on max-width we really saw that she was
the perfect character for this story and
that's the way we we really like to
think about characters just making good
characters and it can be a male or
female characters I really don't like to
put any any pressure on we should do
this thirty male male characters or we
should have a female character you just
work on the characters that's the best
for what you want to talk about for your
project and I think it would be a good
character if children is this way it's a
good answer that's great I think I think
I hope that the industry was sort of
trending this way anyway but then with
the controversy that came you know last
year primarily um I think it kind of
expedited the process almost right it
was sort of like weirdly even there was
such a horrible thing it sort of
jump-started that like with female
characters being more incorporated into
games and sort of random I did which we
shall came to which is very sweet of him
I did a GDC talk last year sorry about
with an educator and we surveyed a bunch
of kids and
how they play games what kind of games
they play and we found that boys don't
really care what protagonists they play
as and girls have more of a preference
to play as women so it actually kind of
makes more sense to put female
characters right in your game because
guys will play it either way
I mean don't all kids will kind of play
games no matter what but girls have a
larger preference to play as girls so
it's almost right you can see also with
life is strange that it doesn't really
matter the gender people can relate to
good characters so yeah awesome life is
strange is awesome it's out right now
the first few episodes all three of them
go get'em I'll play episode 3 so Alexa
will sound your sugar you go finish
episode 4 you get ready to record
episode 5 go buy life the strange that's
it have a great III everybody say oh
here for more games kind of funny